welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is he/she Mizzou's and
today i'm joined by andrew cielito who
is a business psychologist and
performance coach so thank you for
coming up all the way from summer as
well as I do really appreciate it Andrea
it's a pleasure it's a pleasure to be
back in the East End yeah and as you
said used to sell on the market 19 it's
not too far away from here right yeah
Roman Road Ida market still here about
25 years ago was you actually selling
then knockoffs I used to bring stuff
from Italy so it was like Armani soon
yeah money suits Max Mara philotheus
what was I always wonder if things like
that like the did they do you let people
know that this isn't real or like I
don't know what's the deal with that I
mean no it's real it was it's wrong with
one offs why not like it just means that
it you know if you work in retail
because I was in in those days working
in retail in the wreck trade and you'd
buy ranges because you always get those
stands and then I'm like do people buy
them thinking that it's like real but if
it is actually genuine then it's real
it's not fakes and that's fair enough I
love that so and Andres was just saying
where where I love to start and I know
your your story's definitely different
to the normal people there and come in
the studio but what how tell us a bit
about the story and when you first sort
of Van Gogh exposed to the mad world of
recruitment and and what that journey
was like and so I got into recruitment
the recruitment industry yeah like I'd
obviously lots of friends growing up in
the recruitment initially so it's always
intrigued me sure
but join the s3 in 2009 yeah up until
then I'd always worked in sales you know
the market stalls and then I've sports
background so I was kind of doing that
yeah and then got some corporate
exposure work for yellow pages yeah in
the field doing advertising marketing
sales and then just by chance fell into
consulting where someone approached me
said could you come into
about your sports background and talk
about mindset nights and so on and in
those days it was all very new to me I
was interested in playing yeah but I was
going to go to via phone yeah and just
talking about leadership and mindset and
locker room spirit all that kind of good
stuff and then decide go freelance to
2008 which is terrible
yeah said it kind of the whole world
changed yeah and then got approached by
history to look at a role heading up
there leadership development training so
my role was to look after a team of
asam's had a brilliant team who were
designing delivering training in the
business globally yeah and then my role
in addition to that was doing some
executive coaching high potential so
those that were looking at moving into
that director role yeah okay so just a
quick one on that because I've I've also
have heard s free now a lot since I
moved up to London I severe mind little
recruitment but when I was here right
what was your perception of s free
before you joined it like did you have
any grounding on what this business was
like because they've also got a huge
reputation right yeah yeah yeah did you
have any personís yeah all right so I
did ask about in fact my girlfriend at
the time yeah I worked in recruitment
okay and she knew several people that
worked and they heard I was applying for
this job they were like yeah that's
pretty tough on history and I always ask
that cuz I'm always curious because like
it's been the spawn of so many
businesses yes and spoken about a lot so
yes you had so you had a bit perception
then and some people let you know what
was like and it's tough but that's why
it's successful and yeah and and I loved
it did you love my time Esther oh yeah
did you know about well did you know
about this 9:00 a.m. rule
I thought someone spoke about on this no
no all right okay so I think it was and
it was you know you may or may not know
and bit I had them Andy Simpson on here
from Stoke and he got me the job at s3 I
do phonus I had him on here so I are
yeah so I asked him about s free and his
experience what what she went on there
to sort of create this culture and or
listen II you mentioned a non non animal
which is just a simple rule that if if
you're pretty much not there before 9
a.m. or you come in late or whatever
then more than likely you're gonna you
can't see the dawn and see you later
sort of thing okay cool that's really
interesting so how long was you there
for two and half years or okay yeah just
over yeah yeah so and I think that's if
we start with so you helped billion
managers as well is that right although
that was kind of what our sweet spots we
designed some training for four billion
managers and you know as a consultant I
could come in and sort of identify where
where was where we're gonna get the
biggest bang for the buck and me that
that billion manager role was was so
important to that the scaling the
business year growing and if you could
master the billion manager role play a
coach role yeah then for me having
worked with lead you know leaders in the
corporate world I thought if you can
master this role yeah let's uncover that
a bit because I think I'll be really
valuable for people because and that
that's that can be a real pain point
you're right I've heard that a lot in
terms of recruitment business owners
saying they're they're struggling to get
that next layer of leaders yeah and and
then also there's also the pain point
for hi billion recruiters who sometimes
and like shorten experience that the CEO
here where and he didn't really have
much of a choice it was he was told that
he was gonna be a billion manager and he
basically had to recreate five six seven
eight more of him Ryan
so let's uncover that a bit then so I
guess from from your previous experience
in seeing his billion managers what was
what was the biggest pain that you saw
that they were going through I think one
is training for a start that not much
from actually get much training but what
did you see that you tried to yeah get
hold of and coach them on straightaway
for me it was I think it's actually
evolved they've lost ya years as well so
I think you know there are some
similarities some of the things we were
teaching it s three cool and clearly the
time is the challenge but time it's but
the cop out really when you say time
yeah it's really how they're choosing to
spend their time so certainly it was a
couple of things but one is equipping
with those the tools and techniques to
to be a coach and in empower those
around them etc which you think do you
think everyone can be a coach I think
anybody can can learn
because I think some people transition
much quicker yeah and we see there's a
whole different debate about that yeah
it makes a good manager because you'll
see people that are really strong in
process restoring and managing
day-to-day activity and can can go on to
be just really strong managers but often
in what we see is that they might lack
some of that those personable skills the
emotional intelligence trying to teach
that emotion intelligence and visionary
etc and so it's just it's getting people
to play to their strengths for me for
the building manager role is it's one
learning the tools and techniques so one
of things we talk about is is it's been
out to mentor away from the game okay so
to build relationships away from the
game you know get just I'll have a
conversation often what happens away
from the game is a conversation about
KPIs
which it can be disheartening closed
session yeah so we so what we encourage
is just you know let have half an hour
go for a walk you know yeah build that
relationship away from the game and the
better the stronger the relationship is
away from the game away from the sales
floor the tougher you can be in the game
yeah what about so then what better than
the ok so then it's when you hear like
your managers trying to be your main
sort of thing right there's there's a
line there as well and absolutely is
that what you mean by light then you can
be tougher in the game if you've got
that more sort of relationship outside
of the game it's still a professional
relationship I mean sir I expect is a
great example yes so people the red face
barking at people shouting aggressive
manager that we talked about but then
you speak to players and they'll refer
to them like a dad yeah and how do you
find that balance between you know
absolute absolutely being held
accountable yeah in the game in the
dressing room yeah but then have this
kind of mentor that you can look up to
you away from the game and that's that's
the biggest challenge for the building
manager and often what we've seen that
we see in sports professional sports
where the conversations are only in the
game do this do their and better at that
now you're on I try that and after why
you like just get off my case all right
first yeah but after a while but if
you've got that relationship away from
the game you go yeah coach no problem
yeah yeah so what types of things and I
guess is it just like uncover just to
understand a bit more about that person
I understand I don't know more what's
gone on their life besides what's gone
on in those falls in the office light is
if a ninja that is worth trying to find
out or is it just generally just trying
to build some some relationships well I
always say to the sports coaches that I
work with know everything about your
players really manifests itself at some
point yeah but but it's not therapy and
we have to be very careful help get it
easier conversations trying to solve
people's deepest darkest problems that's
very different so I don't I'm not an
advocate of having that type of
conversation because coaching is about
where are you now where do you want to
be talking about the future in the
present versus going on in past but if
that happens but the point is yeah you
could talk about I mean I'm above a
manager and my performance had dropped
off a little bit yellow pages yeah and
he was like you know who's really
curious about it but at the time I was I
was just buying a house and it all got a
bit wrong and I was had to drive into
the office where we had an office saying
buddy no but office I was living out
with bag at the time and were our
friends and and I was driving had to
drive an hour to get to the office and
in the end I stopped me you know stay
into the office and and he just had a
conversation about about the house and
what they could do to help me of that
you know and make it a bit easier and
all of a sudden you know I'll never
forget that conversation that's why I
was gonna say yeah those quiet I've
experienced that myself definitely my
previous director he he helped me in in
that outside of the game if you want to
keep calling that that and those moments
you don't forget them like and then a
hundred percent I couldn't agree more
that it does build that relationship he
was stronger if they they helped with
that certain element yeah that that's
really powerful isn't it for sure so was
it is anything else then that springs to
mind or was that a real key part of it
also so the point I was making there is
if if Billy managed can focus on three
things okay Ronnie's mentor away from
the game yeah performance coaching the
game okay so looking out for staff you
know you're busy
yeah doing your own work you know just
hearing positive stuff when you hear a
girl call or you know making a note of
it you don't deal with it then or if you
notice something that where some might
need a bit of support a bit help just
that performance coaching yeah around
the desk sitting down and listening to
calls etc yeah when you've got time and
and then doing training once a week so
you find something so we call that on
the training grounds if you think about
a sports perspective you enter away from
the game you're coaching in the game and
then you're doing training you know
training ground one of the three areas
but every manager has to focus on yeah
and if they can systemize that you know
an even game of fire in some way yeah to
say right if I have I trained this week
I've done a 20 minute session on biz dev
or if I had done some it okay if I done
something you know what's that what's
the problem my team right now that I
need to run some training on if I could
do half an hour
8:30 before we start yeah great you know
if I if I mentored someone everybody's
month yeah I done some before if I give
some feedback to somebody yeah you know
daily that's not then if you do that and
systemize it yeah then just goal in your
own ability yeah that may that makes you
sound when you're quite simple as well
when you will you break it down into
those three sections isn't that makes
sense and okay something I'm interested
in because I've had some bad managers in
the past and this this is just my
perspective but I think sometimes you
get those managers the that haven't been
like they haven't grown within the
business right there they come
externally right and some of the bad
managers I've experienced that way is
that when they come in they feel like
they have a point to prove in terms they
do yeah oh yeah of course
no as in like okay what I mean by that
is like more stamping their authority
right as opposed to building
relationships yeah and what's your view
on that because like obviously yeah of
course have a point to prove
yeah I just mean more of like they want
to let everyone know that like yeah they
have the authority yeah they're they're
their manager those sorts of things yeah
and for me from what's work better for
me I'll see everyone's different but I
feel like if I was a new person a new
manager I'd want to understand probably
more focus on that out of the game stuff
before before I start saying hi guys
bang I'm your new manager do not mean it
so what yeah what's your thoughts on
that well I think I think so some part
is that people grow out of that yeah
because it not coming with that
vulnerability yeah it's not mentioned
vulnerability to you know one of a
better word alphas and a take charge and
and and have that sort command and
control yeah it's really coming from a
place of insecurity yeah and no you're
right right so right so once once people
start to accept that and go in and ask
questions the biggest shift from the
manager to leader is is when I go you
know I'd have the answers okay what do
you think self-awareness that
self-awareness and and just trying to
yes humility and and just and showing
some of that
mobility and that's what we see in in
great leaders but you know uh I was a
manager at Yellow Pages first thing I
did was you know as a top form would say
this is how I did it just follow that
yeah you know everyone when recruitment
a lot yeah meritocracy so not you know
the the top performers don't make great
leaders we know that yeah can we teach
them well we can but they often comes
from a some sort of Epiphany yeah okay
or desire because it's just not working
out and we see a lot you know just go
back to billing because that's where
they planted their strengths last last
thing on the billion manager pizza we
may come back to about a thing so what
from your experiencing because of CV
you've continued to work with billion
managers not just in s3 but later on as
well in your career so what's been like
the most common habit that's that's how
the billion manager back using that
common mistake or whatever it is that
you've seen that has prevented them just
to become that leader or that's at peace
yet what have you seen a lot of billion
managers do I'd say the thing that's
probably held them back how it holds
them back the most is lack of patience
really yeah that's you know you remember
that there that they're going from in
the game go go go no just playing and
then all of a sudden they've got to slow
it down and go right where am i guys and
I think I part of that as well as it
like they have less control of what of
obviously your center needs to be
patient but they're actually being
patient on other people getting it right
and what I mean by that is in luck and
control of that they can't pick up the
phone and do the best bet for their time
to go oh yeah that that's one thing that
I bring that to the company switch on
and off there so I mean not because I've
heard that a lot as well where Billy
manager found it really tough where
they're doing this new role and then
they'd expect people to do things how
they do it yeah go I mean and that's
also really challenged as well yeah ok
cool what about what what what about
what what did really successful Billy
managers do it like what what is it that
just focus on those three key areas or
what what is it the good leaders do a
lot of there's a lot of things we could
talk about there but some focus on your
top performers okay get rid of Deadwood
nice yeah some yeah like that yeah
recruit for everybody yeah
if you've got an angelic view that my
top forms will keep performing and I'll
just get these guys up to speed you know
sometimes in recruitment and any any any
sort of high performance world sports
any any kind of industry where you know
some people aren't cut out for it yeah
you know and and we've got to get to
that decision pretty quickly now so
being slow to hire quick to fire type
stuff and and and because you you're
doing that person injustice by holding
on to them yeah it does what I've heard
the lies that it holding on to that
person it does actually more damage not
just for them but also the team as well
it can be quite as a team different
levels toxic I mean and that's another
debate yeah somebody's a top performer
who's toxic all right you know in your
dressing room now he takes one bad apple
to make the team underperform regardless
of how good they are that so there is
that but you know I people talk about we
can only recruit an attitude and so on
and I'm I'm not a huge believer in that
because you know as a as a you know
coached at a high level in sport so you
have a bit of a luxury when you it's
particularly coaching the international
team a group of people say because you
get the best the best of the best so you
look for skill first yeah and look can
they can they skate can he stick handle
can they shoot do all that kind of stuff
and then are they right cultural fit for
the dressing room are they gonna fit
within this and then and yeah and then
that secondary and I and I've been
encouraged recruitment companies to to
do to have the same approach you know I
might say well they've never sold before
well you kind of tell if someone can be
you know I mean you can yeah if they got
that DNA for sales and and how are you
going to interview them in a way that
the
cultivate if she knows that bring it and
then once you go actually you know what
I think this person's cut out for sales
now are they right cultural fit yeah you
know do they fit into our into our
organization and then you can and
there's loads of debates around that ya
know if someone's you know got that DNA
for sale yeah now let's go inside a bit
more because I think that's always an I
put out to the audience quite a lot
saying let me know if there's a new
topic you want me to cover and I think
it comes up a lot and what what should
we look
what should we look out for that gives
us the best chance of investing the
right person for them to be a good
recruit a lot what key attributes what
what key personality traits whatever you
want to call it so you mentioned the DNA
or cells or whatever what what key
things that would you try and keep an
eye on is it is it resilience is it
patience is it confidence whatever it is
what
what would you say do you think
resilience is definitely yeah important
I think a a desire some sort of proven
background a desire to do well yeah I
know so often we said you wanna make
money you can make my great best you
know and yeah it's you know you know
that people that are inherently a little
bit more selfish and you know and make
good yeah recruitment consultants um I
think that's a given but um but I've
just looked for that ambition that Drive
you know that that's um you know even if
they fail horribly you know but selling
something in an interview or something
like that but the fact that they gave it
the then you kind of go actually this
person's got that that a little bit of
going them to try and at least show that
they can sell something and then we can
just give them the framework and the
process and this put but you know if
they don't show any of that yeah that
desire then you for me as well it's like
trying to tap into and like I know I
know obviously so many people using that
but trying to tap into that person's why
in terms of like it's very easy on and
loads of money but if you understand why
they want to do that there that that can
also help you make a good judgment I
think if I'm telling you I want to make
six figures this year and you said why
is that Hisham will have a real
motivator to enable my parents to live
the life that they wants it right
yep that's if you if you can tap into
that and understand that hopefully that
should mean that when you do have a [ __ ]
down recruitment and free interviews
fall out they can fall back on something
that that that wine that that that
motivator and that's going to help with
did you go I'm inside you mean yeah and
I think and I think it's that because a
lot for me and and also a proper quiz
will understand when they help Canada
get into another job or even then they
take the job because of that either
personal connection with that company or
the people that they met and and also if
it can really tap into light then
getting close to their purpose or
whatever do you not I mean so I think
it's that coupled with look trying to
stop talking about ib4 and trying to
understand what why does this what this
person want to get out of this and how
we can help them get closer to that you
know I mean it's far it's far more
intrinsic you know yeah and we could go
you know I talked about my book about
the kind of simon Sinek wine yeah yeah
he talked about Apple and I think that's
a very different wine I said yeah
marketing message and I think a lot of
businesses that are trying to go you
know they've watched a video and they go
right yes let's find our wine you know
it's been in two days I shut out around
a lot now yeah and it I think it's
there's a misinterpretation of it you
know simon Sinek is a marketeer he's
he's coming with a marketing message and
it's very powerful
yeah to have that why uses Apple as an
example yeah but really is using Steve
Jobs is why you know so so when business
say to me or can you come and help us
with our wine and it's a CEO I see I say
well sure why because you're why is the
business why yeah what I mean so it's
gonna start from that now you can you
can get your leadership team around that
idea and get them to believe is that
pretty much what you say when people say
that then there's a lot what's your why
yeah bit stylin when I first when I left
s3 yeah my first three or four clients I
was in the corporate went back into
corporate world as far as a Ericsson
virgin yeah AXA PPP yeah you know big
big years oh that's right yeah so
there's you know and it was all about
this why yeah and so actually if
anything Sami did is create a lot of
work for me but I got stuck I went in
and I starting I was getting caught out
because you know you get a group in with
my why's this and yeah some will say
yeah my are wise to change the world and
then you get someone say well actually
know what my parents with nothing yeah
and my wife's coming work and yeah and
to work in and make some money so I can
give it back that's very different yeah
motivation said getting everyone aligned
so so if a business you know if you any
of your business owners are watching and
thinking yeah we want to get really
clear on our why it's got to start with
the business owner that's might that's
just my opinion yeah you know what's
your why cuz
Steve Jobs was ruthless about challenge
the status quo thinking differently etc
etc and and if you weren't bought into
that then you can survive in the
business and you think if that if that
business only gets that right it helps
them make better decisions
can imagine across all different things
right if they really nailed that down
and understand it might be I'm assuming
it hopefully should help them make
better hiring decisions better financial
decisions under for the business is this
gonna help me get closer to achieve yeah
yeah I would say so and if you can align
the business to it you're gonna get it
right through to business you get that
golden thread so yeah what you want to
be looking at is the what and why so
what is to achieve X amount of yeah you
know revenue which is our kind of
service of the business the wire is to
serve others hmm right so even if you're
trying to come into work to make money
for your family your cert you're still
serving others is a selfless act yeah
yeah so when people say well seems to be
a vision or Y a purpose and mission and
all these kind of semantics I would say
what and why what do you want to achieve
as a business yeah why why is it
important to you so who are you serving
through your y1 put that together your
vision you've got its bit of a rational
and an emotional the ocean the rational
which is we have to make money we've got
to drive the bottom line yeah but
actually if we could do it in a way
which is meaningful and purposeful and
then everybody through the business buys
into that yeah and you're off to the
races because he you know that's that's
the Holy Grail mm-hmm it's just a bit
it's a process to that yeah yeah and I'm
sure so then just to frame up a bit more
than so so he was a two and a half years
at s3 yeah yeah
and then so after that as you said went
into the corporate clients as you just
said yeah and then did you continue to
recruitment businesses or did that how
did that materialize it can you get more
work because you worked at s3 and that's
kind of how it was quite organic okay so
so what happens I got a client yeah you
know someone would ask come and speak to
them from recruitment remember we did
for us s3 well that's probably a good
con let's get into that started so many
businesses from that as well well there
was that yes so that was one of the
benefits but um at the time I was doing
corporate right so I was going so it was
a small to medium-sized businesses
saying this is how the program looks
ours what it would cost
yeah looking like I was crazy but I was
just kind of like you know in that
corporate world and then a few more
clients and I said I think you know what
I'm having so much fun in within the
recruitment in really and it was just
just real people I wasn't yeah you know
bring brought in by HR and sort of a
tick in the box
this team it was you can work directly
with the owner of the business real well
yeah and you could see change happen
immediately and and and sort of work
with that business so by 2016 I would
say I've gone from 90% of my work being
kind of opera corporate and attempt to
complete reversing and then in 2017 I
think was - it might be 2016
I clearly there's retreated team coach
brand was kind of doorman it was the
idea behind it was I was doing team
coach and that was my self the back of
my I went to universe you know did a
masters in organizational change and
kind of recognize that team coaching was
my my thing that's where you could have
the most amount of value yeah I just
said it I enjoyed it and treated team
coach was was that was the proposition
yeah but the brand sort of lay dormant
for a while and then I thought you know
this is a good brand for recruitment so
we just completely rebranded and and
positioned strategic team coaches a
recruitment rating company yeah and
that's and that's really I mean you know
just from a from my marketing
perspective and leashing and you know
yeah I think working out period that's
really valuable isn't it it's tough yeah
yeah you do yeah I mean I was I used to
joke about it in 2012 they say what I
just focus on billing manages yeah you
know your visitors to the introduce too
small it's not enough and then and
that's what we're doing and the
businesses as thrived on it because
people get us and they know what we're
doing we and we love what we're doing
it's weird that isn't it when you can
really double down like you there's a
huge part of you or just fall in your
head or voice wherever say you're
missing out and way too much it's
working and then just go all-in and
that's what we did and then and also now
it's sort of growing outside of yeah so
what's so and cool so let's talk a bit
about that period and work on these
recurrent business etcetera what's like
the most common thing that you get
brought in to do or or help them change
it sector what would you say is the most
common thing that you do I know you said
billion managers yeah that's our
flagship okay we've got a protocol goods
great run by Mike what my business
partner so that is aimed at senior
consultants who are perhaps plateauing
or they work a bit smarter and more
efficiently to how that bill more yeah
so you know you you might get you sort
of hit that wall
so 200 thousand pound bill and they want
to get to that half million so you help
with that right that's what your
business product that's that's an
interview with Mike Walkman yeah I
really I think so yeah that's his his
bag and he knows it inside out and that
and he comes from he's been a top
performer he's built teams and yeah
so I'm sure you you've got a bit of an
opinion right I guess what what do you
see that the best builders do a lot of
light because what I really the last
question are someone on here was and
what what does your day look like you
like build a lot I think that's that's a
big thing like that how do people
structure their big a phone bill
meetings big a phone bill yeah more
meeting okay nice fair enough but yeah I
don't know but you've been around these
people rather than eyes anything that
strikes you that you see a lot of when
you come across big billows or whatever
is anything that I know everyone's
different and has their own way but
there's only any similar traffic I think
it's so diverse you know you'll have
someone who can let you make all their
money on the phone no and not not have
that many meetings be but I think in a
in a world now where there's so much
noise and automation and so on that that
personable approach you know getting out
and meeting the candidates getting out
and meeting the client not not taking it
for granted you know so if you've got
Google communities now yeah massively
yeah and and and also be you know I know
it's a bit cliche but to be a thought
leader in your sector so you're gonna if
you can Aneesh and I think what we'll
see and we we we do on the billion
manage of course now so we're doing you
know on the camera yeah mainly because
we teach a gravitas and yeah how to
communicate and hold a room you know as
a key leadership skill but I think now
for consultants I mean media training is
it's going to be key a key part of this
where you guys have you know the ability
to project the voice through through the
camera yeah and even you know even the
quality of it not just what you say but
the delivery of it the lighting
everything is going to become so much
more important though and I think that's
going to be the transition yeah but I
don't think can ever take away getting
out and meeting the pill got to do that
legwork and still do
for sure scanners remember that forever
yeah you know we need to understand you
know that's yeah now that that's a huge
reason why you know candidates different
kind of going you know what it's much
easy if you ever met the consultant to
go I'm not interested yeah exactly
I think I'm hearing a lot you you may
hear this or you've you've heard it for
a while but I think recruiting
recruiting businesses now that they
don't want to be perceived as just a
business that gets bums and see it's
that's like they want to get as far away
from that as possible they want to be
maybe they've already fought this
because you've been in the industry
longer than I have but they want to be
seen as a real service provider they
want to be seen as an extension of their
clients businesses do you know I mean
and I think that's that's a huge part of
it what you're talking about so little
just interested in intrigued then what
what what what and what sort of things
you talk about to help people get in
front of the camera like because a lot
of people are scared of that and they're
run if you scroll through your LinkedIn
newsfeed now it's just videos everywhere
yeah I mean anything that what yeah how
do you help people get over that or any
advice on for people to who think and
I'll I've seen these videos everyone
yeah start doing them like well there's
a couple of things first thing is that
what you said about being more
personable is exists forever
yeah right so it's just that the
platforms have changed you know so the
idea of trying to separate myself and
engage with a client and customer
service and and have a client engagement
strategy as you know that's been around
for a long time so I think people the
danger right now is that people are
gravitating towards it because it's
easier yeah you know it's nicer but at
some point you've got it also do the
introduction yeah which is a cold call
right so it's going to be both yeah yeah
yeah so you know and I remember making
my I mean even the piece of work I got
I'm shaking you know making this even
and I'm a seasoned South you know I
worked at you know page for years know
that I'm talking about making just a
cult you know business you scratch you
know in 2012 and just phoning up people
they usually I sit still
I used to dread business yes do yeah you
still get that weird feeling in your
tummy right yeah so you know it's kind
of its like the pregame that isn't and
what's the worst case scenario so yeah
so that there's still there's still
gonna be that element regardless of how
we communicate online how we communicate
you know
and automate things so on there's still
an instruction at some point yeah
with someone you've never met before and
that's where business development comes
from so so so so that's keep as far as
the actual video is concerned I think
the challenge we've got the MoMA is that
there's so much stuff out there hey I've
got this candidate you know and it's
just you know you can just sort of
scroll through it yeah I think and then
you've got the the how-to so you know do
this and try this here the five rules
and I've done that right so but I think
the things that will separate
consultants is their ability to tell
stories yeah and definitely storytelling
not not even a personal story but you
know let me tell you about a candidate
you know that and there's a there's an
art and a craft to that and the way to
structure it and you know every story I
was beginning to learn anything so
there's that there's something to be
taught there and I think if if if
consultants can start getting to that
mindset of sharing case studies but in a
subtle way through storytelling you know
and make the candidate the hero or the
client then then and that that's what we
you know insight selling and data and
wrapping all up in an emotional story
which is why teddies yeah so popular
it's data wrapped in an emotive story it
works and I think if you can do that in
a minute and a half yeah on LinkedIn
nothing if anyone's listen to this and
thinking yeah you know what all I see is
videos on my LinkedIn newsfeed trust me
like that doesn't mean you shouldn't
start the the market is I know it looks
like like everyone's doing that yeah
trust me they're not there there's a lot
of people that aren't willing to get in
front of the camera and it is still such
a huge window of opportunity and I think
yeah don't don't made a decision of
right can we get in front of the camera
and all I'm going to do is talk about my
jobs that yeah but don't do that and I
think and cuz I'm I was preparing for a
to London for the tiara and actually
about some of this stuff and nothing if
any recruits right now was to scroll
through their their posts if they were
to look at the ones that they spoke
about jobs and then the ones that
they're more in lines of storytelling
sort of spoke about how they have
today yeah that that one is always gonna
have 10 times more engagement yes do you
know I mean so 100% can't agree more so
and what what I'd like to dive into now
is so the four keys right yes is so so
this is your so it is called that your
your new book that's coming out the four
keys yep so what are what are the four
keys business body relationships mindset
nice so where how did you build that
because I really believe in that I think
and it makes it simple doesn't it if you
get those right then you're in a pretty
good spot
but what yeah how did you come to that
conclusion of right okay if you get
those right then that should hopefully
help yeah but it's there's several kind
of evolutions or sections to if you like
personal and then how I kind of
introduced it to a group of people yeah
and so on so so the kind of context
behind it really and that I mean I've
always talked about business and mine
say yeah you know there's kind of two
for the last ten or fifteen years that
has always been my my sweet spot the
relationships and and even body even
though background sports so whenever you
need businesses it normally you'd be
talking about these things right the
business the mindset may be a bit of
health but ya know it was kind of
winging it really a sense I mean it was
just not winging it but it would come up
in conversation and I could bring just
my own support my own experience of that
but but to kind of give a very short
overview I I came from a family of
bakers so in my job you know from the
moment I was born was to be a baker
my dad granddad was a baker yeah based
in North London moved to Thomas Wales
had Baker's my dad took it over and and
and always the fam fee yeah anything
else and but my dad sold the business
when I was 11 I was devastated and even
then I'd kind of this entrepreneurial
Flair of what we could do with the
bakery and they're nice and so on so is
it was like the whole world just sort of
changed but my dad was convinced by a
friend of his to move into the property
market and and so he moved into property
market be fair to be made a lot of money
yeah with big houses in time which world
holidays you know this beautiful blue e
type jag that you know that was a big
fan of classic cars but as creeley's
made his money he lost a lot but when he
had the money he was enjoying life you
know
so he was enjoying the the good life the
game way and he was a sportsman as well
so that that kind of stopped his his
relationships become dysfunctional with
my mom during that time as well so once
we had all these nice things things were
kind of sort of falling apart and then
and then the eight is the property
market sort of just crashed and and we
lost lost everything so everything
downsize yeah and and then you see it
now you know you just didn't have the
agility to kind of fight back it got fat
and people we see this in now you know
people get metaphorically getting fat
you know yeah you know and getting a big
house but yeah yeah yeah a lease on the
on the Range Rover and etc et-cetera and
and we were seen by Aussies getting
divorced and yeah one Sunday night but
that came to the room and said Andrew
I'm going to bed come give dad a hug and
I said man I can't give you dad I can
anyway he went to bed that was last time
I saw him so young so you know you know
is I mean it's I mean I'm 43 you know
it's so so he yes he he died of heart
attack and it's just stuck with me and I
don't know if the work I do now with
business leaders is borne out of that or
and I think that makes a lot of sense if
you sort out your own eyes it's
something that you'll see cared about
and you know how important it is yeah
and how much of a negative impact it can
have on everywhere else in your life
yeah absolutely and then even when I was
at your pages of seeing it I mean I was
seeing like my dad and every people that
growing a business start the business
their best advertising and then I'd work
with him over three years and then you
kind of go what's going on here yeah you
know divorce or they've gained weight on
the business and the business suffers so
so that so that kind of has always been
in my mind yeah and I think maybe one of
the reasons why I got into the into the
coaching but so fast-forward by 2016 I
was you know I'd been the head coach of
Team GB via Rollo key we had the best
results ever I'd written a book about
yet yeah I was thriving
coaching practice everything was going
brilliantly to you know to young kids
and elder daughter you know three
for kids my wife everything's going
brilliant yeah you know and then some
wife turnaround zealand sign up for this
yeah for this you know it's like what do
you mean you know everything's great so
you realize it's not and you don't hear
the warning signs so certainly as a
business owner so I started talking to a
few of my the business owners that I was
working with and they were going mate
this is this is real you know this is
the same you know everyone seems to be
having this same whether it was their
health or and my health deteriorate I
was suffering with arthritis and it was
scenarios it's more to do stress and I
was getting gout and I kind of start
researching that and why I was getting
out my family joke about it some a dalit
gout and they say anything you left me
but so I started really looking at this
and and that's how it kind of manifested
its you realized it was actually and
then around you that serious case a
couple of shoes because I was I was you
know doing the world and then thinking
actually I've you know it's between
Dubai New York traveling all over the
place and you know it was there a
certain moment then Lyon I tell you
didn't see the warning songs and stuff
what was there in mind moment wait like
like these things are really starts to
deteriorate around me and things wife
moved out I know you're fine now but you
know it was a real kind of in slightly
how do we become more proactive about
this stuff and and and so so yeah so we
so we looked at so I introduced a few
people and then we create this
mastermind
you know I launched mastermind and the
guys were coming back saying this is
game-changing like we are having and
then some of you watching this you know
that you know they were just literally
game changed and the results so I was
still I still had this kind of business
psychology sound I said look guys you
owe me to run a seminar on you know so
we've got and zoom or something like
that on Facebook to me to do something
on business and structure and processes
and they're like no no you know we're
just going all-in on our body our
relationships our mindset my business is
literally taking care of itself
whereas I think we get so obsessed with
the business yeah so so that so that was
a real that was a real shift and that
was back in so that was 2017 yeah so I
set Mike one of my so we had these
90-day game plans yeah and I said his
guys look my nights day game plan is I'm
going to write
aboutness just what we're doing with
your case studies and yeah and so on and
I set myself a target to completely but
by the end of the year and and a few
other things and online program and
stuff like that like big weird these
goals that we said would scare us you
know let's come up with things that just
scare us but if we can compress time in
ninety days we can perhaps what is that
about we've been speaking about that as
a business more think of it as like a 90
day stretch and yeah what is it about
that
that helps I guess realize it or not not
make it seem as big do you get what I
mean what yeah I think it takes from a
dream or an aspiration to something
practical just makes it more practical
and yeah actually realistic achievable
in the next days that's gonna get me so
we started doing that in it and then but
even you know what can we do between 8
and 12 mm each day you know when your
most common weather your brain power is
stronger you know and what are some of
the things that we just don't like doing
it if we can just get them done yeah
yeah yeah well in life you have that you
have come one foot on the accelerator
one foot on the brake so you've got one
foot on accelerate towards the vision
and this idea and then you've got this
kind of yeah but I don't like doing that
and that's why not everybody achieves
their full potential because they don't
want to do the work you know and all the
heavy lifting or the stuff that's a bit
uncomfortable which might be you know
set yourself a target to put 10 videos
out as a concern I'm going to put I want
to do it I hate it but I know it's going
to be more business if I just put 10
videos out over the next 90 days yeah
just set yourself a metric like that
which is aligned to the division
division how big is accountability
through that length because a lot I
think that Facebook groups and things
like that that's that helps with that
isn't it I guess you're sharing it with
the group because yeah if you'd if an R
you don't do that you know that these
people are gonna hold you accountable
yeah you know so we didn't call it a
mastermind at the time it was we just
that what's that group yeah yeah get fit
to him what's that group here and some
people more focused on the health some
people more focused on some were focused
on business and we're focused on
relationships all the above and yeah
just that and we would post our 90-day
targets and great like that same you see
them and I share some of them in the
book some decay studies get an example
of and that cut is quite different some
other
our ferry metric focus is on so metric
folks but but either way it says some
sort of level of outcome that I'm
working towards I think I've heard that
a lot look I'm big into my podcast self
development all that stuff and I think
and yeah I've heard a lot recently about
like yeah if you get that Fitness right
in terms of really taking care of
yourself and and also the mindset has
got to be in that area like everything
else should hopefully take care of
itself
yeah so obviously people that you are
gues you experienced a bit that yourself
and all the people that you speaks in
that the business is doing fine and I
guess a lot of people would think now I
have to really really focus on the
business which is why I don't have time
to do these mindset stuff and the body
but actually you can focus on that
because that will take care of itself
maybe even do even better when you do
believe like you're gonna come more
productive they've got more brain power
yeah you're going to be more effective
you can be a better person around those
people around you so so I'm not saying
you know stop drinking do deer so yeah
there's nothing like that
but there are some you know one I think
so talk about the book is it always
ready you know what you do today is
entertainment how ready you are tomorrow
yeah so so if you if you're gonna go out
and party then you know don't be
surprised if you're not as ready as you
want to be the next day or whatever so
yeah so it's just a choice that you make
but yeah the the bit you can make the
business thrive but that other stuff
will catch up with you so if the
relationship becomes toxic you know
you're not going to go to work the same
person I know if you're going through
some some trauma around that if your
health is deteriorating when I stood up
at an event just when I got the idea and
I said to Nancy if you all get your
three year plan you're all here so it
was a conference of recruiters in here
so you've all got your three year plan
I said here's what's gonna and you've
told your partner it's all gonna come
good and all that kind of stuff happen I
said that you're Paula might be there
the money you've got you can spend on
medical bills yeah and there's a danger
here kids and and everyone come look to
me as they literally in my living room
and that's how it was started so so a
lot of that water so I really like the
relationships plan I think rarely would
I really do I speak to people about
relationships in here and I realize I'll
feel it's really interesting so
I guess you can talk from your own
experience but what did you start
because I think it makes sense I guess
in any anyone who's a guy that's really
driven by their business purpose let it
cetera et cetera
yeah there's so many guys out there that
that's what really drives them and
that's what they really focus on right
and so when they do get home with the
missus a lot of time they're not even
there right they're not even there with
them even though I present present yeah
so guess what
an in and in recruitment and
particularly obviously you got young
guys absolutely working their ass off
young females doing that as well
it's normally that they stay lay and all
that so I think that's that's a really
important element for sure that I don't
really speak about that I've experienced
myself so what things did you start to
do or change to help your your
relationship then have an impact or what
other people have spoken to about as
well yeah so some one thing is about
being present if you're if you're there
you're present and I think that's that's
many thing get rid of the phones and
yeah and we will do it right I mean
we've all you know if I caught myself
the other day my little one asked me a
question I was kind of yeah I think
that's what I mean because a lot of
people can get caught up with so if your
and partner's going are like you're and
you know spending lost harmony etc etc
guys can easily go what I've been
spending reason in review whatever but
what she's actually saying is like when
you're here you're not you're not I mean
hundreds and I think it's like don't
don't think are okay well no I've been
here all evening with you what you're
about it's actually even if you spent
less time so let's say you only had an
hour when you got home if you're
completely present with that person and
that hour is gonna be long enough do you
not I mean so I think hope you get
caught up with that don't know there
absolutely and also you know that
depending on if if he or she is the
breadwinner or something like that you
know well I'm bringing in the yeah we
have a nice you know and all that kind
of stuff as if it's some sort of
justification for not being present so
that less one thing but what we're not
talking about here right so I'm not
talking about its work-life balance
mmm-hmm because there are historically
you know our ancestors it you go away
for days you know time you know weeks
you have to do the work you know and and
and I think we've probably lost that
that idea that you know that we're not
gonna be around all the time you know we
might be working late we might
to travel and stuff like that it's it's
what let's it down is the lack of
proactive thinking say right well you
know in February I'm little way working
away for a week I know it's gonna be
really intense for a period of time just
my lifestyle is that I work too late
every night yeah what do I need to be
thinking about to build in that time so
right I need to book that that time you
know whether if you've got kids it I've
got to get the babysitter sorted just
take some control yeah of it obviously
you involve your partner with it but
it's just that that level of proactive
thinkers when it's all go go go all of a
sudden you know it's it's we come up for
February before you know it it's
November yeah so it's more about it's
not necessarily right well I'm gonna
start I'm going to work and I'm stopping
at 5:30 every day yeah it's no actually
I do work too late so what can I do to
make up for that yeah build that time in
a proactive way I like that I know I
agree yeah I think obviously well off
balance is getting shots around so much
non yeah and I don't think that just
simply means well I'll work I'll work
less or whatever and I have more free
times you know I mean it's something
more than that yeah I agree and ok last
pit before am bit ok cool we've got
we've got a bit time and we start
wrapping up Bert okay what about the
fitness part then because I'm quite
passionate about that and I think um for
me my personal experience been in in an
office environment and you hear diet
talk every single day yeah I'm trying to
start this week next week it's not
working like I hear it all the time on
Monday people are in good spirits or
whatever yeah and by the end of it
they're they're on fat Friday getting
getting those meals in yeah yeah and it
obviously it's a it's a it's a constant
challenge and I think yeah in the
workplace it's a lot more and evident I
think and you hear a lot more of that
conversation so and I couldn't agree
more
when I felt my best but now and also in
recruitment is when I made sure that I
made time to to workout or exercise or
whatever yeah like 1,000% and I'm sure a
lot of people would agree with that so
what what what things did people start
changing in your mastermind group or
whatever that helped them that you can
talk about or share yeah it's good
question so I think when we when we
first got into it now
I my my views have changed actually
particularly for and even just from that
experience yeah you know come from a
sports background if I wasn't training I
was getting weaker yeah you know what I
mean I was actually over training and
getting weak from the trainer yeah yeah
yeah so that's one thing I think we need
to be mindful of is that we don't have
to train as chronically as we we think
yes should you know so when I hear
people say you know I've got I've got
out shapes I've signed up for the
marathon I'm like you know when you're
gonna be out all Sunday
running you know so that's gonna impact
your family you know yeah yeah so so my
views of you know if you're if you're a
high-performance athlete you're gonna do
things that are proper good for you in
the in the hope to win the goal yeah
there's good you know that's just
reality but we don't need to be walking
around in fat so I take very much an
ancestral approach okay my race this has
never worked out yeah they have to
sprint every now and then yet yeah
not everyone can sprint for whatever
reason but but every you know I always
say to people you seven to ten days you
know just in sprint a little bit you
know if you're gonna train in the gym
you know my my mindset was and even
people that train with me up until about
a year ago is you leave nothing in the
gym you leave everything in there you
just everything's to failure yeah you
know and then spend the rest of the day
just know if it'll mean or overeating
now because you just want to eat
whatever you can get your hands on which
causes information and all that kind of
stuff and even hot chronic training you
know it stimulates cortisol it's a
stress hormone yeah then you're going to
work and the more stressed and yeah
so so my views of training have changed
dramatically and so how I work with so I
trained as a health coach last year just
to help help my clients a bit better
sites I could give some some sort of
some good information they can make an
informed choice and and just slowing it
down
you know strength training hugely
important particularly the age yeah it
doesn't have to be three to four times a
week you know I can imagine it being
more focus on like just full body light
movements yeah yeah you know distraction
as well right and all that last movement
stretching and but bringing that kind of
strength element yeah into it and this
different weights to strength training
body weight you can do you know you pick
up the barbell yeah
but you know I did the four days a week
CrossFit stuff or you know you know and
you know you kind of the whole like the
cycle is CrossFit intense yeah try
Somali lifting get injured recover back
do it again get injured you know I think
I think I think a lot of people have
that about it I think a lot of people
have that perception as well which
prevents a lot of people star as well do
not mean that they think they are young
getting back at the gym so they
associate okay so that means doing all
those things that you're talking about
you know I mean that you've now changed
yep something that also puts a lot of
fear into people cause a lot on how can
I can't do that but I think you're right
I think and yeah having less of an
expectation that you don't need to go
there and and walk out there not being
out to push the door open clue where I'm
so hard you know I mean it's really and
we did some studies actually we used
some equipment we work with a
recruitment company and we did a study
on those that trained at lunchtime nice
and people that were training quite
aggressively and open like really in
today stuff and we could see that their
cognitive ability dropped wow I mean so
so we know that it doesn't that was
interests in fact the people that went
out for a walk were far more effective
loved cognitively in the afternoon and
stressing their body like that that's
really interpret the most important
thing particularly for consultants
business owners is what you you know and
and if so if you're looking to get lean
if it can to get stronger feel better
cognitively it's it's it's really down
to what what we and I think there's some
really good hacks around that but people
could think consider you do know yeah I
think so you know and certainly eating
and people people will challenge this I
mean stuff came out in the news this
morning we've gotta eat more fiber and
and I have another I mean I don't eat so
you you're on the key on the key I
remember now
right now yeah it's well carnival month
so I've not eaten anything pop of meat
really really yeah yeah so totally kind
of wonder moment yeah that's just an
experiment it's yeah that's fun
no I think what feel pretty yeah no I
think we just said the experiment is the
important word that I think everyone's
looking for that that golden bullet
everyone's looking for that that one
diet that's gonna save you I think look
for my I'll comment on your recent post
about obviously the the vegan diet nor
that I was vegan for
and a year and a half and I was
vegetarian for light free--free is Ryan
the four V in me during that period was
like oh yes and I think but and then
look I had a bit I had a bit of an
epiphany myself and I realized I think
for me you gotta listen to your building
there was a moment where I was like you
know what when I do eat I feel like I'm
I feel bloated a lot more than I did
I started have more stomach aches and I
was like you know what this diet is no
longer serving me however when you're
when you're in that what that world
which I understand is that you can
become it is almost can become a bit
more of a cult and this light at night
if you look how many when you gotta go
on a particularly is because I'm the
I've gone it done a 180 I'm totally yeah
I I've done the same for and my
partner's still a vegan that's all it
looks like a torn-up cooking chicken
flies it is a tough one but you know
what's the purpose behind it we'll be
doing it and then you get into all
different ethical arguments and and so
on probably not but not for this podcast
but what about jesting trusting your
literature yeah accent cuz all I see is
people just eating sandwiches every
lunch and yeah I know that doesn't so
people are like in terms of making sure
that they maximize their day buffing the
energetic cognitively etc etcetera yeah
everyone reaches for the mill deal rain
fog
crazy so what what things have helped or
little hacks whatever that people can do
it's okay okay you go work for me in the
science that I've worked with and and
because they have different different
goals lose weight get leaner yes feel
better perhaps they're trying to reduce
information and of stuff I'm a big
advocate of the the ketogenic diet you
know I know that this this morning news
came out saying you know I've got a fire
burning of carbs and all that kind of
stuff I think that's just industry news
I don't believe it yeah keto for those
that not sure what it is it's a very low
carb down high fat moderate protein I
think it's very sustainable
that's what's been working for me yeah
it works and it's certainly - levels
that you know having suffered gout for
15 years and just limited that with by
the way there's a process a transition
should I say there's no I don't want
anyone to go that sounds great I'm just
on carbs for yeah seems to be felt I've
never done like four kids seven months
but I
I'm a local and I definitely yeah even I
just yeah that's what I'd call it that I
don't like to consume a lot of carbs
yeah and some of the people I work with
it perhaps more active and they are
training you know I'm not a big fan of
long endurance training but if they are
then there's anything between so yeah
hundred fifty grams of carbohydrate per
day yeah still low for most people yeah
yeah couple of sandwiches and then it's
insidious
so so those that put on weight between
the age of 20 and that's what we see in
recruitment don't we you know someone
comes in to visit 23 unrecognizable
because of insidious you know and a
couple of pounds on a year yeah so I
think there are ways to maintain your
body weight I mean I'm probably you know
I feel better now and I did in my 20s
you know I was in high carb diet in the
gym three or four days a week and and
then hockey as well so I'm a fan of out
there fasting you know again it's
fasting today I think it's what you said
is a lot of fun I everyone's different
and some people need their breakfast I
should be that like that but for me
especially in like a thousand sales
environment like I feel like that window
of when you get into the office 212 is
like such a productive yeah point and
period and I think for me I don't I've
done all it is but I just feel more
productive more clear-headed when I just
feel like it's slightly empty and I just
feel like we could do some ketones as
well so yeah that'd be you know even
though insta mr. pfaster would produce
ketones a cleaner fuel for the brain
than glucose oh yeah you know that
that's just yeah I think you know I mean
if anybody wanted to send me a message
and some advice and I'm happy to yeah
give some advice but because it too fast
you know their citation they don't eat
yeah yeah and it's doing fasting and
starving yeah you know starving will
cause stress response put you in fight
flight and you get off to fujian and
that's not very nice so so yeah it's
you've got to be fat adapt it so if you
can get to 12 o'clock without eating
then it's probably cuz you've we've got
plenty of fat on our body yeah and now
the body's using that as a fuel source
rather than glue
whereas if you come in have the
cappuccino there you know the the the
breakfast and then you think I would
have a snack it because I'm you know so
insolent you're on the insulin roller
coaster yeah so as a top four you don't
want that as a business you want to be
you know I'm obviously I'm delivering
training people always say to me how you
know it's five o'clock you still get you
know and it's like and I I'll get that
well I think for that is like how can
like there's this learning people out
there you just every time at free get
coke it just doesn't make sense to me
that like they'll and then they'll just
do the same thing the next day yes you
know as sugar arguably is more addictive
than cocaine so you know it's people say
I stopped it you know so and then okay
it's hard yeah it really is is it's a
difficult transition and and but I
always say to people if you if you're
going to work with me from a health
coach in perspective cut out sugar and
grains for 21 days so yeah just do that
say I fell yeah and then call me in 21
days if you can commit to that then then
we could start the work I think the
important thing to underline is that
which why we got onto this is that if
you generally do take a row effort into
that it's gonna benefit you in your
holiday in terms of being a recruiter
working in business whatever okay so and
before I let you go and I like to always
ask this question so be interesting to
get your thoughts on this so and
basically you can answer with a phrase a
sentence whatever comes to mind
and the question I'm asking you is if
you could communicate to every recruiter
recruitment business owner out there
they listen to to Andrew and they'd
implement your advice mmm-hmm what would
you say what would the advice be hear
what the advice be what would you say oh
you put me on the spot there a little
bit so what would the advice because
that you said business owners n so to
try and find somebody it's kind of it
the core of that I think going back to
your point about the why okay
you know just ever ever ever think about
the story that shapes you mmm you know
the because the why is often that is
manifested out the story that shapes us
yeah that can be so powerful you know
once we kind of go wow you know it's a
kind of been
25 years I didn't want to talk about
lost my dad yeah sudden you know it
became empowering rather than there's a
dark cloud only so some of those stories
you know they can be really positive
story something might be some that you
kind of just yeah but that's something
for me in that you know just you know
what's the story that shapes you you
know that we could do psychometric
testing all that kind of stuff everyone
knows that
yeah about but you know and I I talked
about it in the book but you know a guy
that Sam I was working with in the
Middle East and and did a psychometric
test he's my everyone knows this about
me and you know but he this kind of
interaction yeah I went I would give too
much away but it he identified a story
was so compelling to him as a leader
that it just changed the whole dynamic
of his team what do you shared it I
really like that what's the story that
shapes your life yeah so that before we
finish we mentioned it briefly before we
and countless tears probably shoulda
spoke about a bit more but and so you
got this new book coming out when's it
coming out be on Amazon January
fifteenth and I believe the publisher
runs it for like $0.99 or power 99p
where you are in the world yeah it's so
for a week for a week bar get those
sales up yeah I think the public you
know it gets the the bestseller strategy
to do it so fun you gonna buy 15 cause I
know I know you spoke about a lot of
thing and you shared a lot about your
perspective your opinion and set for I
think as I said a lot of recruiters
listen to this so if how do you feel
about other night if one or two people
were to reach out with you and share I
don't know would you think a golf
they're their biggest goal of 2019 or
then 90 day yeah what would you think
they're let's see what we could do on
the website yeah there's a survey okay
and on your website yeah yeah I'll put
I'll put the link on there yeah and you
can send a survey actually put a link on
there the first five people that
complete the survey I'll send out five
books okay
is there anything they need to put on
there to indicate that they listen to
this podcast it's a good point just make
it just say yeah I somewhere on that on
the questionnaire yeah yeah do that yeah
yeah and then just put a code called
first five people that fill out the
survey I'll put the notes and
yeah the show nights in here and within
this survey just put in big capital
letters the recruitment rollercoaster
yeah and podcast and you will work
yourself a free boat first we appreciate
that well it's an absolute pleasure it's
been a pleasure thank you thank you mate
yeah thanks